you've got two sounds I think we've got
a picture of you here just after you
gave birth
no that's Charlie he's now almost
Three's two and a half and that's now -
we have River Joe who's one and he's -
now is it Charlie who's like a sort of
little mini-me well yeah yeah a little
bit a little bit I see you know you
start you say things and then they they
repeat them he says a couple of things
that I say my dad and this is probably a
regionalism used to say asses and elbows
meaning we'd be in the kitchen washing
pots and pans and if I if I participated
I'd be kind of mmm-hmm and you come on
let's really get in their asses and
elbows so now Charlie I'm often in
charge of seeing him brush his teeth and
teaching him that that takes a while so
he kind of you known does a little bit
of this and I go come on asses and
elbows and he says it's fun to hear him
say asses and elbows I heard him say I
guess I said it he said oh yeah these
y'all I said you like those pancakes
yeah never in my whole life
what you say never bipolar Yuri over
three and a half years
gracyk your son that seems remarkably
unimpressed by your career yeah yeah
yeah he really couldn't care less
he doesn't believe you're the real deal
yeah I mean he's now you know fatherless
he'll say he's five and three-quarters
and he and he went to Universal the
other day Universal Studios in LA theme
park had a good time and came back and
he said hey Dad guess what today I saw
the real Owen but I think there's this
guy a universal who dresses up like my
character from the movie he's like does
this thing and the kids he's like no I
saw the real one day working is that
every day yeah
all year you up see you know you have
your parenting rules and all that but
currently the what is it the parenting
rules change if you go fishing yes
that's right that's right
we have a we have I have a farm up in
Washington State and on on this farm is
a lake and and it's we fish a lot for
bass on this lake my son and I and I had
this rule with my old man and I have it
with my son which is when you're fishing
you can swear he can just swear when
you're fishing it's just the guys go
ahead and let loose and so we're out
fishing he catches a fish and I'm trying
to get him to take a picture with the
fish before we let it go and it flops
out of his hands and and these baths
have these little spines on the on their
back and the fin pokes him in the hand
and falls in the water he starts to cry
and he's like oh ho and I said hey buddy
are you all right you all right he said
Oh dad I'm about to swear hey you know
you know the rules and he goes that bass
that bass is stupid well you know I
think we say hey don't say someone
called someone stupid that's bad you
shouldn't say that nice and he's
continues to cry since you feel better
he said a little bit stupid stupid bass
and I was like all right buddy yeah you
know now's the time get it out and he
goes
stupid bass is a [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
you